und bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner neben büros vorsitzender der fdp
hat sich einen handelsüblichen
schutzraum eingehandelt als er von der
gratis mentalität sprach und mit dieser
gratis mentalität dass neun euro ticket
in die ewigen jagdgründe verweisen
wollte aber so leute das tun sie hatte
damit recht es ist ja sogar noch
schlimmer wir haben eine
vollkaskomentalität in deutschland meine
ich dann immer etwas mit links soll der
staat zur seite stehen und der stadt
macht das sehr gerne weil der stadt hat
liebe abhängige untertan als freie
bürger das ist das problem wir haben mit
die höchste steuer und abgabenquote in
der ganzen welt glaubt nur belgien ist
in europa noch vor uns der staat wird
immer fitter immer träger immer in
aktiver und ab und zu verteilten kleine
plastischen gut zwischen bonbons damit
der untertan nicht allzu widerspenstig
wird statt einem staat der immer wieder
die klientel gefüttert die am lautesten
im moment gerade schreit es also einen
staat der immer nur scheinbar gibt
gibt's gibt bräuchten wir ein staat der
viel viel nehmen weniger nimmt wenn wir
nämlich eine geringere abgabenquote
geringere steuern für alle geringere
mehrwertsteuer auf obst getreide und
gemüse ein höheren steuerlast
pauschbetrag um für das alter vorsorgen
zu können et cetera pp dann wären wir
alle wieder freie bürger wir könnten
mehr verantwortung übernehmen wir
könnten mehr für unser alter für uns zur
nächsten zu lieben vorsorgen und wir
während weniger in diese abhängigkeit
allerdings der staatsschutz diese
vollkaskomentalität weil er eben gerne
die gouvernante ist die ampel steht und
dem deutschen michel die nacht kappe ins
gesicht zieht haben wir ein problem mit
den deutschen meinte
also ich finde dass ich finde es
wunderbar wie das eben vorgetragen
worden ist und ich finde auch gerade
diese des kenia trios auch durch den
neuen euro ticket und den tank rabatt
also sind ja wirklich so gut dies die
hin gewordene werden wo man das gefühl
hat okay wir müssen jetzt mal was rüber
bringt entlastung wir reden momentan
über alle möglichen entlastung die
parteien überbieten sich wir haben die
wahnsinnigen ausgaben für die bundeswehr
durch den ukraine krieg wir haben
riesige ausgaben für corona also wir
haben doch mal darüber gesprochen dass
wir in deutschland so eine schwarze null
haben wollt ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
noch nie war erinnert so das ist ja noch
gar nicht so lange her und die leute
schäuble geht ja jetzt hat man das
gefühl es ist für alle alles da also das
finde ich schon sehr problematisch und
es dadurch entsteht natürlich das gefühl
dass jede klientel grüner sagt okay dann
holen wir uns das als nächstes steht
abhängigkeit ist nicht einfach so
schlimm wir sind nicht eine republik
sondern wir sind eine gruppe mehr oder
wenn der und verbundener opfergruppen
anspruchsberechtigter und jeder bekommt
ab und zu mal sein kleines flüsschen
gestellt und dann gehen wir wieder
unsere wege sind still und schreiben
dann wieder den stapellauf und dann
kommt der staaten futter und früher hat
man doch mal gesagt wir müssen auch an
die nächsten generationen denken ja die
nächsten generation die diesen
schuldenberg irgendwann abtragen ich
habe das in letzter zeit nicht mehr
gehört hier geht es immer nur darum dass
aufzubauen und aufzubauen ich finde es
sehr sehr problematischer
sauer dass eigentlich nur noch darum
geht zu verschenken anstatt auch mal zu
sparen habe große sympathie für das was
der doktor kissler gesagt hat er bringt
das auf den punkt was natürlich gerade
auch selbstständige oder leute in
führungspositionen oder ähnliches bewegt
dass eben die arbeit sich teilweise dann
tatsächlich nicht mehr lohnt das ist
natürlich schon spürbar aber ich will
einen ganz wichtigen punkt sagen ja auch
auf die gefahr dass ich mich unbeliebt
mache ich glaube sie hätten diese dieses
dieses narrativ nicht gerade am neuen
euro ticket fest machen sollen denn das
neun euro ticket empfinde ich als steuer
zahlen der bürger als einem ganz
wesentlichen schritt in die richtung
dass der bürger zum beispiel versteht
was mit einer möglicherweise durch
klimaveränderung jetzt notwendigen die
in der regierung ist noch der wende
möglich ist ja ich rate von geschwiegen
ich will ich will mich ist es einfach
ein psychologischer effekt aus aus aus
meinem lebensumfeld denn ich
festgestellt habe aber länger 9 euro für
immer müssen es neun euro sein könnte es
nicht auch 39 habe ich eine frage an sie
ja ich kenne jetzt nicht ihr gehalt das
muss ich auch gar nicht kennen aber ich
kann schon beim jetzigen erschüttert für
mich muss der staat keine neuen euro
tickets zahlen ich brauche es nicht
jetzt ist die frage ob sie das brauchen
diesen zuschuss ich glaube halt einfach
muss man dieses dies kann trier sid
machen das soll sie mal nicht vielleicht
lieber dass er ja wie sagt man es durch
einen schlauch auf die menschen zu hören
sich an kommen über das
gießkannenprinzip können wir nachher
nochmal sprechen aber das ist doch genau
der punkt nur da sage ich gerade das
neun euro ticket hat aus meiner sicht
psychologisch gesehen für mich als
bürger als verbraucher einen eine
signalwirkung gehabt ja hier hat sich
doch mal zumindest spürbar etwas bewegt
in der politik
gibt es wahrscheinlich arbeitsstätte von
bisschen sind sehr wie groß war die
wirkung des neurotiker also dass jetzt
alle oft auf die bahn umgestiegen sind
das waren ja wirklich überschaubar sein
überschaubare zahlen und ich glaube
gerade dieses gießkannenprinzip das ein
entscheidender punkt meine tochter
arbeitet nach ihrer ausbildung in eine
arztpraxis hat einen sagen wir mal
überschaubares gehalt und für die wahl
dieses neuen euro ticket super logisch
ich brauche ich nicht ich brauche dieses
neuen euro ticket nicht genauso wie
jetzt wo über das energie geld geredet
wird und das ist doch das hauptproblem
das wirklich mit diesem
gießkannen-prinzip die gelder diese
milliarden summen die wir ja alle zu
steuert das ist ja nicht das fällt ja
nicht vom himmel dass die ausgegeben
werden und da muss man doch viel
zielgerichteter vorgehen wirklich für
die leute die bedürftig sind also wenn
sie es nicht gebraucht haben hätten sie
es gar nicht kaufen an brauchen aber ich
werde jetzt erst mal kommen ich bin
jetzt erstmal zum thema zurück zur frage
der gratis ich halte das für einen sehr
verheerenden begriff ich kann ihnen das
auch erst mal erklären zum einen haben
sie etwas vollkommen durcheinander
gebracht vielleicht rosa schnee und 20
davon gesprochen wir hätten hier die
höchsten steuern abgaben gut das ist so
nicht richtig
sondern wir haben hier die situation
dass kleine und mittlere einkommen
tatsächlich am stärksten besteuert
werden was ein großes problem meinte der
aufklärer aber das ist nicht ganz
richtig weil ein vermögen und hohe
einkommen mit am geringsten hinterher
auch in der europäischen union so gab es
heute auch noch mal eine studie das hat
die oecd auch im bestätigt das heißt wir
haben massives ungleichgewicht an dieser
stelle aber wir haben sehr viel aber ich
habe ich sehen dass es noch mal sagen
herr lindner hat das gesagt nachdem er
dann einem ist es halt machen falsch und
fakt vorgeworfen das ist kein falscher
verglichen das stimmt nicht ganz an
dieser stelle sondern man muss schon
gucken wo das heißt wenn man er sagt
allgemein ist es zu hoch stimmt einfach
nicht weil für hohe einkommen und für
hohe vermögen sind die steuern in
deutschland halt einfach nicht sondern
richtig und höre dann bleiben wir
endlich mal das schade der frage der
gratis mentalität an dieser erstelle
denn an dem tag danach war es glaube ich
ist lindner dann abgedüst nach süd zu
seiner hochzeit hat dafür auch
öffentliche gelder in anspruch genommen
was die sicherheitsdienste
beispielsweise am rande das ist nicht
grade dabei hätten sie selbst wurde
wright oder recherchieren sie das
richtig arbeiten ok dann dann tut mir
das leid am hohler frage aus oberkassel
nachfrage hin konnte der deutsche
bundestag da keine antwort darauf geben
wir haben das nachgefragt müsste man ihm
genau dann wäre vielleicht ganz
entspannt an dieser stelle aber reden
wir beispielsweise über fossile
subventionen 65 milliarden euro jährlich
gehenden fossilen subventionen gratis
sozusagen und das schadet dem klima das
kostet den deutschen am start geht bei 9
euro ticket habe aber eine andere
situation wir wissen mittlerweile zehn
prozent der fahrten die sonst mit dem
auto gemacht worden sind sind im mit der
bahn gemacht worden das ist gestern grad
im rahmen bleiben band der deutschen
verkehrsunternehmen zogen gestern haben
rausgekommen das ist relativ gut in
einem sogenannten autofahrer im land ist
eine gute zahl das ist der zweite faktor
ist auch co2 eingespart worden und zwar
in drei monaten so viel co2 wie
beispielsweise und tempolimit von 130 in
einem ganzen jahr gebracht er hätte auch
das entlastet das staatssäckel das
entlastet auch das stadtparlament lassen
dadurch entlastet mit diesem neuen m
euro ticket aber ich glaube glaubt weiss
nicht ob die zahl stimmt kann aber seien
drei oder zwei oder zehn ich bin ja auch
oft bahn und ich kann nur sagen wer zum
ersten mal bahn gefahren ist eines drei
oder zehn prozent im rahmen der neuen
euro super duper los waches wochen er
fährt vielleicht eine schnellbahn weil
ist knallvoll war als gestunken hat wie
hohle aus den toiletten heraus weil man
gewartet hat auf engen bahnsteigen her
weil die hauptbahnhof ich war vor dass
dann jeden tag einer tod- ausgezogen
wird also diese drei mal neun lovatos
locker wochen aber man könnte ihr einer
werbung kann können wir sagen dass wir
die dvd er muss besser werden